foreign visitors of course a lifeblood
for our tourism-driven economy but it's
a lifeblood that's largely been cut off
for the last year and a half hector
mejia joining us live from the las vegas
convention center the trade show ipw
officially underway and hector they are
working to bring back these
international travelers i think thank
goodness we can all breathe a sigh of
release
hey there an ipw is showcasing not only
las vegas with this booth here but other
american cities too international travel
operators basically providing content
they need about those destinations this
is really helping our economy and jobs
recover as we rebound from the pandemic
ipw brings international buyers in the
travel and tourism industries they'll
conduct about five billion dollars in
future travel transactions over the next
three years when it comes to las vegas
we'll get to see about
467 million of that the las vegas
convention and visitors authority says
international travel has been close to
las vegas for the last 18 months or so
president and ceo steve hill talked
about the economic impact for las vegas
they are
15 or more of our visitors in any given
year
when they come they tend to spend 50 or
60 percent more than a domestic traveler
so
the 15 visitation becomes 20 or 25
of what is spent here in las vegas this
year our attendance is about half
usually there's 6 000 people here
we have almost 3 000
there's over 300 buyers the biggest
buyers travel from around the world
other big conventions coming to town in
the next few weeks include the
international wireless communications
expo plus in october the american rental
association national hardware show and
national business aviation association
convention
there are also about 300 journalists in
town checking out what's new in las
vegas for example the brand-new resorts
world writing about it and sharing with
the rest of the world what's new here in
our town reporting from the las vegas
convention center hector mejia 8 news
now